Game of Thrones has been heralded as one
of the greatest shows of all time but
that adulation has not shielded it from
criticism viewers and critics have
called out the HBO series for its
gratuitous sex and nudity Emilia Clarke
appeared in numerous nude scenes in the
first season of Game of Thrones often
times without any clear plot related
reason to justify the stunt since the
actress was 23 with only a few acting
credits to her name she was
understandably uneasy not wearing
clothes on set to make matters worse
Clark's first intimate scene on Game of
Thrones involved her character being
sexually assaulted by her husband while
filming the upsetting scene with her
cast mate Jason amoa he did his best to
make her feel at ease and protected
which is what every young actor deserves
from their scene Partners Clark told the
armchair expert podcast that Momoa took
care of her and was so kind
inconsiderate toward her she added that
he demanded the crew give her a robe to
cover up and keep warm between takes
Clark's account of momoa's onset
Behavior proves what a warm-hearted and
thoughtful performer he is